[Music]
hello everybody my name is milan i'm the
author of modern fortran building
efficient parallel
applications uh it's a book by manning
publications so in today's stream uh i'm
gonna
basically guide you through live
programming of
simple yet
functional
way physics simulation
in fortran first i want to point you
to a recently developed
community project the url is fortran
lang.org
and basically it this website aims to be
the home of fortran so basically it's it
describes what the language is about
you can
read the latest news there's a
newsletter that comes out uh there's a
twitter feed
then we have a mailing list that you can
subscribe to usually
that's where people post theories on
news announcements and so on
there's also this course forum uh which
i'll show you just in a little bit and
of course the github repositories of the
projects so the main projects are
uh the fortune standard library you may
or may not know but uh fortune itself is
a relatively small language it doesn't
have a comprehensive standard library it
has
what we call
intrinsic functions and
subroutines and modules so they come
built into the language they're
available in the scope
right away
most of them you don't need to
import
or anything they're just there but they
mostly focus on
mathematical and array
numerical operations a little bit of
a character string manipulation
but it's there's not much going on in
terms of a comprehensive standard
library like many other languages do
for example like
python so
the fortune standard library is an open
source community project that aims to
provide
de facto standard
library for
fortran and i'm gonna show you its
github page right now basically on this
page you can
read more about it
the scope how you can contribute
documentation so right now
there's a full api documentation uh for
the standard library on
stdlib.fortranlang.org
okay so back to projects then there's
also the fortune package manager i'll
say a little bit more about it in a bit
because
i'm also going to use it in this stream
so i mentioned the discourse earlier
so we started a fortune discourse about
six weeks ago
there's quite a few interesting
discussions already on the forum
if you're interested in fortune learning
more
if you want to ask for help
definitely
check out this course come here yeah i
welcome everybody interested in in
fortune and contributing to these open
source projects
today's stream
okay let's start so
we'll go completely from scratch
um
so right now i'm in vs code
i only recently started using vs code uh
before that i used atom
i used vi a lot
in between for
small stuff but so far i like vs code
better than atom it performs better on
my computer
they're fairly similar in terms of
functionality but really
any editor that
you're most comfortable with
will work what matters is that you have
syntax highlighting and a compiler the
the most
widely used and most easily available
open source
compiler for fortran is
g fortran it's part of
the gcc so g fortran is pretty easy to
uh to download and set up
on your computer so on linux
it's basically available from your
system package manager if you're on
ubuntu or debian you'll be using apt
if you're on fedora santos red hat you'd
be using yum or dnf
to to install g fortran okay so
and you'll see i have a few files here
python script that i'll use for plotting
uh fortran is not that great for
plotting for graphics it's certainly
possible uh
to plot so there's interfaces
to opengl
gtk
sdl
uh
from fortran which so through them you
can you can do graphics but
really for right now we just want to use
the the simplest solution imaginable
and yeah this is just a very simple bare
bones python script
that i'll use to plot it don't worry
about it right now and i also have
a few shell scripts that i'll just use
for convenience to
to automate converting images to a movie
and to batch run a sequence of
operations
okay so let's start with our project i
mentioned earlier that i'm going to use
the fortran package manager to
set up and run
our little project and so let me take
you to
fortune package manager and fpm right
now so this is a pretty young project
and basically it aims to be both a
package manager and a build system
and the number one problem that it aims
to solve is the user experience
installing
building your fortune package getting
dependencies
all that doing it by hand or writing
your make files or cmake lists can be
quite
tedious uh complicated and sometimes
just plain uh
difficult for larger projects and
fortune package manager aims to make
that
really easy
so
i mentioned it's a very young project
but it's already quite capable and i'm
gonna showcase uh in this stream how you
can use it for your fortune project
okay so what i'm gonna do
i already have fbm setup
on my machine but i'm just going to go
through the steps of installing it
so that you know how to do it
okay so i'm just going to copy the url
from here
let's pull up a
terminal let's see where i am
twitch
okay tsunami that's going to be the name
of our project
get
clone
paste
so let's clone fpm
now
to install it you'll need
a
stack so stack is haskell's
package manager
and build system i guess
so in the readme there's uh
there is instructions on how to set up
stack and then how to
how to install fpm so i'm just gonna i
already have stack installed
so i won't worry about that right now
but to basically install fpm i'm just
gonna run stack install
in fbn directory
and it will do its thing
okay building all executables for fbn
all right 15 viewers i'm happy
okay compile build compiling fpn
almost there
okay so it looks like it's done uh it
says copied executables
to wholemeal and dot local bin
so my fpm went there
let's look
okay yeah we have fbm there and
so
when you do this for the first time make
sure that where fbm is installed that
you set that
directory to your path
uh i already did that
so i can confirm by doing which fpm
that it's indeed that one okay
so now that i have fpm i can get out of
here
and go to my project directory okay
uh
so
the key premise of fpm is that
the user is not supposed to
do any kind of complex setting up of the
build system or
management of the package instead the
user
must structure their project
in a specific directory structure and
follow certain file names filename
convention
so if you're familiar with rust and
cargo this is this philosophy is very
similar to
to cargos
and
indeed we we used cargo as an influence
for fpm
now i'm going to show you the guide
so at the bottom of the readme page
there's the packaging guide
it's basically a short
short text that describes
how to structure your application layout
or library layout
for fpm
and you'll see that here in the
talk there are example package layouts
and then we have single program single
module library multi-module library
various
scenarios that you can have
for your package
and say if you go single program it
tells you
what
the structure
uh basically directory and file
structure of your package should look
like
in order to
build your package with fpm
it expects this fpm fpm.tamul
so that's basically configuration file
for fpm
and for the simplest scenario fpm tumble
it can contain just one line
so let's start with that
let's start an fpm domo here
so i'm going to do
name equals name of my package so that's
going to be tsunami
so tsunami is the running example
in the book
uh basically it's uh
it's a shallow water equations uh
simulation uh
so for those of you
less familiar with uh the physics
uh
of shallow water equations
so it's a very simple system of uh two
equations for
velocity or momentum and
mass conservation but basically it
simulates
an evolution of a wavy water surface
and to do that it solves both velocity
of the water and
water surface elevation
forward in time
so okay this is my fpm
tumble i'm gonna save it
now
let's look at
what my project
structure is supposed to be so we're
gonna have a directory called app
and the main program in main.f90
okay
so i tend to alternate between the
terminal and the editor
i'm still not
a 100 uh use and comfortable with the bs
code so i'm going to alternate between
the two but
i will get it done anyhow so let's start
with the simplest
basically the most minimal fortune
program
so you open it with
uh with a program statement and let's
call this
tsunami
okay
so
anything in between these two lines is
going to be the body of our program
any fortune program must have at least
this program unit
and
it has to have exactly one
if you're making a library you can have
just modules
you don't need to have a program
but if you're making an executable
application
you're going to have a program
and this is analogous to say main and c
c plus plus rust and similar
languages
okay let's print something
hello
twitch
okay
so
now assuming i set up everything
correctly
i can build my project with fpm by just
typing
fbm build
oh wait i'm in the wrong directory let
me back up
so now i'm in my top level directory
let's try this again
fbm build
okay so
let's see what happens
we run fpm build
and we got g fortran
and it says it built
main.o
in this directory
and an executable here
so
let's go and look
to make sure they're there
okay
main.o and tsunami as we expected so we
can run this program directly
uh hello twitch good
as expected
um i actually am not going to be
invoking my program like that uh
every time i compile it because now fpm
actually arounds us allows us to
build and run
our program in the same
in one step and that's by doing fpm run
so
here i typed fp and fpm run and fpm know
exactly where to find the executable
to run it
we got the output on the screen and this
is
analogous to
again
rust's package manager cargo when you
type cargo run it does exactly that
now let's
let's change my program a little bit
hello hello twitch
and if i do fpm run again
fpm will notice that
i change my program so it will rebuild
it
and it will run pretty cool
okay back to our
waterway physics
let's type out um first
uh sort of our statement of a problem so
we want to solve
shallow water equations
let me take you back to the browser so
the wikipedia page for shallow water
equations has this cool
animation that basically shows you what
was the solution
of the equations
and
these are my equations uh
you'll notice that here i listed two
steps step one linear one the advection
and step two shallow water equations so
we're going to work in order here
so linear 1d advaction basically it's
it's a very simple equation
that describes how
an object or a fluid
moves in space
uh due to some
uh
advective velocity
so
because we'll be solving for water
height and velocity here i kept the
notation we have a
partial derivative of h
over t time so that's basically change
of water height
in time
and this equation states that the water
elevation will change in time
due to
a gradient in space
of water elevation being advected by a
velocity so this velocity is basically
just think of a background flow
that is
moving an object with it so
say if you throw a
a twig or a leaf in a stream
water is going to carry it basically
where the water goes so
this u here is the velocity of the water
and
then h is an object except that this
also applies to fluids so
the same
physical mechanism applies to
to fluid as well as
objects
now
the reason we'll go
through steps and start by implementing
this is that
all the building blocks that we'll use
in this more complex set of equations
we will
implement to use for this one and this
is a very simple one so it will
it's a good example for us to make sure
that all the building blocks are
implemented correctly before we jump
into a
more complex solution
okay let's go back to
[Music]
um
our editor and basically i'm just gonna
type this out in the comment
sort of enough
in code
pseudocode so basically dhdt plus u
times dh
dx
equals zero
so that's going to be our equation and
let's see how we can how we can solve
this actually we can solve this
um
on page not not solve it but we can
rearrange it in a
programmable form even without writing
any code
so
if you're familiar with arithmetic
basically we're gonna do some
arranging we're gonna move u d h d x
to the other side so that we have
d h over d t equals minus
u d h
d x
and then d h
equals
minus u
times d h d x times d t
and
now basically i will need to invoke a
sort of
an approximation to these derivatives
and
the most uh
the simplest way to approximate uh
continuous derivatives uh
which is
so this is going to be necessary in
order for us to program it
in code
as you probably know computers can't
computers don't solve equations
computers add and multiply numbers so we
need to
cast this equation in a form that the
computer can understand
so
recall that this dh is a change in h
over time so this is really
h in
the
future
minus h
in the present
which equals minus u
times
uh dhdx
times dt
so dt is going to be uh
my time step it has to be discrete in
order for for it to be
programmable
and okay for brevity let's just call
this
and plus one
next so and n plus one will refer to the
next time step and n will refer to the
present time step
now let's do the same enrique as the
spatial
derivative
so
to do that we're just gonna
express dh but now because it's
a gradient in space we're gonna do a jet
i plus one which is the next
adjacent cell in space
minus h at i
and then we're gonna divide it by the
grid spacing so we're going to express
our
equations and the solution to these
equations on a grid and in discrete time
okay and that's it and basically because
we'll be solving in each step for
h n plus one
our final step is to
move this to the other side
okay so our code is going to look
somewhat like this
and
probably this time we can
[Music]
get rid of these underscores to get
closer to
the fortran indexing syntax which i'll
cover very soon
okay so we have now just
for brevity i'll just keep
the original equation and the final form
okay so let's
let's declare some data so fortune is a
statically typed and strongly typed uh
programming language
this means that
variable types are evaluated at compile
time
this is in contrast to say python where
variables and types are evaluated at
runtime when you run the program
and also unlike python where
variables can change
type
during the execution of the program in
fortune
when you declare a variable to be of
certain type
it stays of the same type for the
remainder of the program
so
let's start by declaring some data and
i mentioned i will be working on a
discrete grid
in discrete time step so basically we'll
be
working on numerical arrays
one dimensional arrays uh of certain
grid size so let's declare that
great
size
and then we also have
a finite number of time steps that will
solve our
equation over
so let's just call this
number of time steps
i just want to give you a heads up
so i mentioned that this is
this is a project that is
the running example in the book
uh
what we implement tonight may deviate a
little bit
from the book so the code may not be the
same i'm kind of
winging it
in the stream
but
if you want to
sort of
look up things follow along
uh
and work
work through this example on your own at
a later time so basically manning put
out this um
free ebook
exploring modern fortune basics uh which
is basically
chapters 2 3 and 4
of
the modern fortune book
and they're available for free
and
chapters 2 3 and 4 essentially cover
developing of this running example
uh in its serial
implementation so the non-parallel
version and in later trackers we get
into parallel
and
i just wanna
let you know that
this free ebook is a really great way
for you to
take a look and get a taste for the book
to see if you like it
before you commit to
buying the full
full copy
so
this is uh again this is available for
free
okay let's get back
i think i say okay a lot
so we have
our grid size and number of time steps
they're both declared uh integer
and another important thing about
fortran that you should know
right now is
implicit none so fortune has this
historical feature it's it stems back
from
you know so fortunate started in the
late 50s
at ibm so it's one of the oldest high
level programming languages but it's
definitely the oldest high level
programming language that's still in use
today so essentially was
fortune is a language that was invented
to
to let people not program in assembly
which was super tedious as you can
imagine
now
for a long time
uh fortune had implicit types
and
basically before actual type
declarations were introduced
unfortunately i think that was in
maybe fortrans
66
uh all variables were typed basically
implicitly
if
and they were typed depending on the
first the first letter of the variable
name so
by default num time steps would be an
integer but
grid size would be a real or a floating
point number
simply because the implicit typing rules
said that
i think from
a to h and from
[Music]
um maybe r or p to z
uh they're real variables and from
i j k element and similar
are integers
so i think i think it was fortune 90
that introduced the implicit none or
maybe it was 477 i'm not sure
but basically implicit none was
introduced to the language so that the
programmer can say okay i don't want any
implicit typing i want to explicitly
declare
my variable names
and
okay i'm gonna
demonstrate to you why that is important
right now so
let's say
let's do
okay my mind is blanking right now um
but the point is
implicit noun allows you to allows the
compiler to catch errors for you
when you use variables that are not
declared
the bottom line is
always use implicit none without
exception it's a good habit to have and
it's a minimal nuisance
so
just do it it will save you a lot of
time
debugging
okay so
let's
let's assign some values to these and
let's say grid size is going to be 100
a simple round number and we'll have
let's say
also 100 time steps
you know what let's do 10.
simpler
small number
okay
so now let's print them out
and
because we'll initialize these um
they're known ahead of time so we're
just going to encode these values in the
source code directly
we can also declare them as parameter
so
oh gee whatever here
i tried to use a vi shortcut inside vs
code that's what happened
and i have vi bindings here but maybe
not every everything is working
correctly
also why is this color red
i'm not sure but
let's
let's run this
invalid character name
another character in name at one
wait what's invalid here
ah diaper
okay
took me a while to spot it
okay
so
compiler says
num time steps has no implicit type that
you mean on tie steps so actually this
was a typo
in my code so let's fix that
let's run it okay and it printed 110 is
the values of these
parameters
okay let's keep going
um
so recall that to solve this we're going
to loop in time for a set number of time
steps so let's
introduce
our time step counter
maybe n
and now we're gonna do
and
doing from
one to long time steps
and do
and here now let's print
and off
long time steps
so so far i didn't mention anything
about this
print star
print star is essentially the
the simplest print statement
before and you can list any any number
of
variables on the statement
comma separated you can even put
literals
in there and it basically uses a default
compiler compiler dependent programming
so print star is
most useful for simple printouts
okay
run
so fpm by default um
also includes
useful debugging and warning flags
so here the compiler warned me that
okay grid size declared here
is unused so we haven't used it in the
code so we get a warning about that
that is fine
uh so now we
yeah basically we looped uh
for num time steps then and then in each
iteration
we
basically printed our time step counter
okay
so far so good
uh and this is the loop inside which
will be
solving
our equation
okay
so
i mentioned we'll be solving for water
height
which we can represent
as as an array to basically capture
a range of water heights in space
so let's declare our first
array
and this one is going to be real this is
our
second type
now
so real let's call this
just h is fine could be height
could be water height
how you name your variables this is
really
a matter of style
uh in general it's good to be
explicit and verbose because it adds
clarity uh to your code
uh but there's also the alternative view
that
for
code that's
that maps directly to
mathematical equations
it's actually it's it's okay and
uh it can be nice to name your variables
after
the mathematical concepts
and
actually you know i was kind while
writing the book i was um
pretty torn between two styles
and i was using this um
the short form uh
style where i've named my my variables u
and h just after uh the variables in the
equations
but i was curious about um
what was the
the take of people and john so so i did
a twitter poll and
there were about
400 responses to the poll
and about 60 percent
of voters uh preferred the explicit and
verbose
uh form and about forty percent
still like the short concise one
i still kept the concise form uh in the
book and i'm gonna use it in this stream
as well
simply because then the code maps really
nicely to
do the equation itself
okay so
h is going to be an array and to make it
an array
we specify its size
in parenthesis
so now this declares
h which is a real
or floating point array
with non-grid size elements that's going
to be 100
alternatively
you can also do
there's a more verbose form to this and
sometimes it may be more readable
and that is
the dimension attribute
and then you just say h so now this says
that h
is
a real with attribute
dimension so the dimension basically
says this is going to be an array and
not just a scalar and its size is going
to be
num grid size
what
makes it convenient
about having the more verbose form
dimension is that now you can just say h
and u and both h and u are going to be
arrays
of
of this size
whereas then if i was list if i was
listing multiple
arrays here
i would have to type again on grid size
okay
for now i don't need a second array
so let's just keep
this short form
so
whenever i can
without it being
super obfuscating i prefer shorter code
over moreover bose
it's just a
personal preference matter of style
in any case when you when you program
you you'll develop
your own style
so whatever works for you
is best okay
so we have our array
and we can easily initialize
all values
to
say if i want to initialize it to 0
this is important because
when you just declare a variable
by default it's uninitialized so you
need to assign it the value
after declaring it
to do so
so we'll just initialize everything to
zero
and
what i'm gonna do is print
and
h
so we'll be solving for h inside the
time
time stepping loop
and for now i just want to print out the
initial state
notice that i actually haven't
initialized n here
so let's
also do n equals zero
let's hide the terminal while i'm not
using it
okay and equals zero
and
let's comment this out i only want to
look at
my
basically my water height array
run
okay error says explicit shaped array
with non-constant bounds at
ah
how did this even slip by so i'm
not supposed to be talking non-grid size
but grid size
okay
by the way i
i expect expect my viewers to catch
errors like this and let me know in the
stream chat
okay
okay so this time around i got a bunch
of zeros
this first zero here is my
basically my initial time step
and then h are all these
other values
now if you put an array on a print
statement it's going to dump all the
elements
on the
screen
and that's exactly what happened so
now let me
run this again and store it into
a text file
and why am i doing this it's because i
want to plot it
uh
so let's just set up um
my plotting
environment real quick
so if you work with python this will
look familiar just bear with me i'm
going to set up a quick environment
i only need matplotlib for the script
okay sources
activate
pip installment block clip
almost there
okay there's a newer pip we don't care
about that right now
let's run this
and
i'm gonna feed the output from my
fortran program to the python script
it says plotting time step zero
let's quickly look at this
ah we went to the other side
okay so
this is the x-axis is my uh
uh basically spatial
spatial index
uh the y-axis is my elevation and this
blue line is just my
zero valued
water height
now before
before we actually do anything with the
equations
let's
let's initialize h to some more
meaningful shape
perhaps the simplest right nice to just
say
that h
in some part of the array perhaps from
40 to
50.
equals to on one
so now here in parentheses
i'm saying
this is a fortunes array slicing
uh syntax
basically it says that all elements from
40 to 50
uh will be set to one
and
the rest will be zero
let's run this again
okay so now you see
there's some one valves here
good
let's write it too
and
what's the name of my image
okay so this
this quick image viewer keeps running
away from the screen let me see if i
have a better way to
to display this
okay so i'm just going to be
showing it in the browser
okay so this is basically a
top hat shape
now this confirms that
i initialize my shape
correctly just as intended
so we have zero
everywhere except between indexes
40 and 50 where i have
value of one
good
so i guess maybe now i can just
good so i'll be using this to
display my
my image
okay so
this worked but let's set it to
something more
uh
more realistic
so something something smoother that the
better resembles uh
sort of uh
to say wave uh it won't be a wave just
yet but
uh you'll get the idea
so what i want to do right now is set on
a gaussian or a bell-shaped
curve
to the water elevation
and to do that i'll need
a spatial counter
and now we're going to loop
from one to grid size
so unlike this loop where i'm looping in
time here i'm looping in space so i want
to loop over each element of the array
and i want to set it to something
each element will be
okay so
the bell shape is uh
is an exponential
with minus
it was so
we want to have
i minus
let's say 50
that centered
square
so i want it squared because
when i is 50 this is gonna be zero
and then the exponent of zero is one so
my water height will be
one when
i is 50 but on either side it's gonna
exponentially decay
okay
so let's see what that looks like
this
uh minus number here is very important
because that's what uh makes a decay not
explode
okay i got an error
x argument of exp intrinsic
must be real or complex aha okay so
basically i try to pass an integer to
the exponential function and
the function expects a real or complex
so
let's
there's few different ways we could do
this
we could explicitly convert it to a real
by
passing it to a
conversion function real so basically
you
you give um
an integer or a complex
number to a real and it gives you a real
number with
with the same value
same
decimal value to say
okay my thing ran
and now i'm gonna
plot it
aha
what happened here
so my planning script broke because it
could not converge strength to fall
to float
i see what happened
see i directed fpm run to my
text file where i want my output to go
but because i changed the source file
fpm also built
build the code so my
my output file ended up with this log
from fpm we don't want that
so
let me redo this again
run out and let's plot it
and then let's refresh
okay
so now basically get a spike with a very
sharp
decay here
there's an easy way to fix this
and basically we're gonna
put a factor here
uh we're gonna multiply
basically we want the exponential decay
to be much much weaker so that we get a
broader
form of the wave
so i'm just going to multiply this by
0.01
now that we're multiplying it with a
float
we don't need explicit conversion
and
here we touch on on
on a feature of fortran that's that can
be treacherous but if you understand
well how it works
it's it's quite powerful and that is
that
fortune has
uses type coercion or
so-called mixed mode arithmetic and that
is say when you mix
an integer and a real
in the same expression
say if you're multiplying a real number
with an integer
the compiler will under the hood promote
the integer to real automatically
and then yield a
real result
so for that reason we don't need
explicit typecasting
and
now i don't want to make the same
mistake
doing this okay fpm run let's redirect
it
and
let's plot
now i can look at my browser
okay much better
uh so now we have this sort of uh c
mount
well not really c mount uh sima refers
to something else
seamount is a mountain
on the
the ocean floor
but basically this is sort of
a smooth uh bell-shaped
perturbation of the water surface
okay
back to my code also now i i want to
automate my
my pipeline
so i had this script
prepared so i can just run that
every time i generate
a new output
so we're gonna fbm build
in a separate step to avoid getting the
log of fpm into the text file
and then we're gonna fpm run and
redirect it into the text file
then plot it
and then this
this other part is will come later it's
for the movie
i don't need it now so now if i just do
run
it's gonna build the code run it and
plot it so i can go straight to
the browser
let's see how i can refresh from the
keyboard okay like this
good
same
cool
okay so we initialized our
water height field
now notice that
because i'm looping over all array
elements and setting sending an explicit
value to them
i don't need to initialize to zero
anymore because i'm completely
initializing it inside this loop
let's remove this
another thing i want to do is
rather than using
literal values here i'm going to set
them as parameters
so that
when i need
them then i can just change them in the
declaration so let's call this
decay factor and let's call this um
i center
so i center is the index
index at which my
perturbation is going to be centered at
let's say 50 real perfect
same for dk let's set it to 0.01
and let's make sure
our code does the same thing
very good
nothing changed
good good good
okay
so we set up our water height array and
now we can just
go ahead with
our solution so now we're looking at our
equation here
i'm just going to copy this
here inside the loop
now this is already i believe
valid fortran code
what we have not set yet are these uh
[Music]
feel these parameters so we have the
background velocity
we have grid spacing which we haven't
set and we have the time step
so we can set them all
here let's do a real parameter
you
let's just say one
dx
1
dt 1
so
in the metric system basically a
velocity of one meter per second
on a grid
with grid spacing so that's the distance
between each element of the array
the distance is one meter
and the time step of one second
it will iterate forward in time
so with
num time steps of 10
our whole simulation duration is going
to be
for 10 seconds
now here if you want to be
pedantic and accurate because these are
real numbers you can do
one dot to indicate a
literal real number or
even more
readable variant is 1.0
so let's do that it's not
it's not necessary
by default
all all fortune compilers work with
single precision
real numbers unless you explicitly
declare it as a
double or higher precision
so let's just do this for
for readability
okay
now let's see
we're not gonna be printing this anymore
oh by the way um
[Music]
there's a cool
cool way to
mark mark up your loops
also if
if branches
in fortran say
uh if this loop has
a special meaning let's say
initialization of water height you can
label this loop by saying say init
colon
and then goes your
your loop your do statement
and then here at the end do you say in
it
so this basically
gives a gives a name uh to your loop so
it helps it helps readability
it's not super useful in single do loops
but when you have multiple nested loops
triply or
four times nested two loops it's
actually quite useful to have
these labels because it tells you
which and do corresponds to which
do and here i can do
say integration
declaration
or time loop i think i used time loop in
the book
okay
uh backdoor equation okay
so main thing is we have declared
h as a one-dimensional array
uh and that's
one the array in space
notice that here the way that i express
this
photo pseudo code actually indexes it in
time
so we don't want that because our
indexing is really in space
so this
h i plus 1 minus 8 minus 1.
that's ok
but this we may just need to
say h i
and h of i so in each iteration we'll be
overriding
each element so basically it at any
single iteration we're only keeping the
current one
uh in memory
and when the next iteration goes it
overwrites
with the with a
solution for the next time step
uh this is okay because we'll be
storing it into the output into the file
at every time step
so basically here outside the loop i had
the initial print statement and now i'm
going to have a print statement
inside the time loop
and what else is missing here yeah i
actually need to loop in space here as
well
so
let's call it space loop
space loop could be a
an ambient music track
one two grid size
okay so now
ah
i need to also finish this base
okay so i'm looping over all elements of
the array
and here i'm doing the finite difference
in space
we're going to hit an issue here because
because we're doing a difference between
two neighbors
if i go from one end of the array to
another
or inevitably go out of bounds
let's see i'm curious if the compiler
will catch that
so
this code should not run
aha
okay this is very cool
so thanks to the
pedantic warning flags
uh by fpm
actually the compiler warns us array
reference at 1 out of bounds
101 greater than 100 in loop beginning
at 2.
okay so that's very useful
the program will still run so this is
not
this is not an error language
totally allows you to do this
so you need to be careful not to go out
of bounds with your arrays
so the program still runs
and we get
the initial state
actually this whole thing is the initial
state
and
i'm getting fortune runtime error index
101 of dimension 1 of rah above upper
bound 100
and it even tells me where
where that error occurred
row 32
column 39
okay i guess it pointed at the end of
the parenthesis but
close enough
so
to fix this actually we need to
not go from
from the very end but start from the
second second index
and then go
go to the end of the array
and
actually there's a very important
property here about the algorithm itself
and
the way
this
spatial gradient stencil is arranged
so in finite difference this is called
first order upwind
differencing
and for our equation and
for this simple solution
it's actually quite important this or of
index is important in order for
for the algorithm to be numerically
stable
okay let's run it again
okay it runs
and let's see what my
output looks like
[Music]
funny enough plotting
plotting results is much slower than
computing the results
so now i have a bunch of files i have an
image for each time step
so let's see what it looks like
so i have it
at
time zero
and then we have
at time step zero we have a good initial
shape and then we have nothing
afterwards so that's not
good okay let's see where i made the
error
okay this point
it's all good here then we enter the
loop
aha
okay here's what happens
as i loop from 2 to grid size so
basically my eye goes 2 3 4 5 6 all the
way to 100
i'm overwriting
each element
with the solution of the finite
difference
from that element
but then in the next iteration i'm using
that updated value in the finite
difference
so
we actually need to do the finite
difference
with the previous time level
so to do this uh
i'm gonna
introduce
a temporary array
in which i'm gonna
do
dh
equals
let's see if it lets me copy it like
this okay
dx
okay so now
do
do to grid size
and let's call this gradient
so it makes code a little bit more
verbose to label your loops like this
but
um
when you come back to the code on
three months later it's actually much
much easier to understand what it does
when you have
labels and also comments
so recall you can comment
your source code with exclamation marks
so anything following an exclamation
mark is a comment in fortran
okay dh
and then
here we're gonna replace
this with the h
okay why was this important uh so now
we're calculating basically the gradient
let's call this actually dhdx to be more
precise
the h underscore dx
so now we're first computing just the
gradient
and we're doing that because the
gradient needs to be computed with water
height values from the previous time
step or the current time step
and we're computing the gradient for the
next time step
so now when we use
these pre-computed values in this loop
here
we should have no issues calculating our
water height for the next time step
what else is
missing we then declare dh
the axle edges do
the hdx
grid size
and
also let's
notice that we're going from 2 to grid
size so actually
dhdx at index 1 is not
initialized so let's
for now let's just do
dh over dx
of one
to be zero
and then these other values we compute
in the loop
let's run it
plotting
did
oh no wait that was just the initial
step
all right
so
eureka
our shape is now moving
to the right and it's moving due to
background velocity u
uh now what i'm concerned about is what
happens when it reaches the end
and that's basically a
question of boundary conditions
in partial differential equations
so boundary conditions
um
basically you need to
you need to tell the system that you're
solving or the program
[Music]
what happens
at the boundary uh to the solution uh
does
does this uh
quantity just leave the domain or does
it reflect back in
or is is the value constant at the
boundary or
does does it appear from the other side
so in the book i do what's what's known
as the periodic boundary conditions
so basically this amount would
goes through the end through this end of
the plot and it it should reappear on on
this end
and
let's do that
so to do this i actually need to specify
what's the value of
dhdx at the first grid point
because my
form is moving from left to right
we're always updating the grid point on
the right based on the grain point on
the left so we need to specify the
boundary condition at the first
index of the array
so instead of zero
actually you know what before we do that
let's just see what the solution looks
like as is but i need to
i need to make a longer calculation so
let's do 100 time steps
and now because
the plotting is pretty slow
let's just not plot every time step but
let's plot every
fifth
so basically this this loop in my python
script
plots for every time step but now i'm
going to say if
if i'm not divisible if my time step is
not divisible by 5
i'm going to skip so only plot
if
uh
if we're divisible by five
you know actually now i realize probably
it's fine i don't care about refactoring
this right now
and at the same time because i want to
see how this involves now i'm going to
enable
my animation
so now the program ran for 100 time
steps and we're going to plot every
fifth so we should get
21 images
and i have
a conversion script
to np4
and let's display this in the browser
okay so
see what happens we have our mound that
just leaves
but nothing enters from the left uh
we we actually want wanted to circulate
so it took it about
50 steps
to leave and actually
the center leaves reaches the edge
exactly time step 50.
seems like a coincidence but this
basically we initialize our mount at the
very center at the index 50
we have hundred grid cells from one end
to another
and in each step we
advect uh
the wave by
one grid cell or by one meter
uh let's see what happens if
so actually if we
decrease the velocity
let's say 0.7
actually numerical properties of this
algorithm dictated that
the object will be exactly preserved in
shape
if
the ratio of dx and dt is exactly u but
now
u is smaller
so the algorithm should should still be
numerically stable
but our shape i believe will be deformed
so let's run it again
and see what happens
i hope i saved the file before running
it
yeah i think i did
okay
let's see what happens tonight
[Music]
did this work
wait a second what if i do
0.1
run it again
uh okay
so
the the deformation is more more
dramatic when i
really lowered the velocity u so now u
is 0.1 so what that means is that
the shape is moving 10 times slower than
it did before
so in 100 steps it only reaches
grid point 60.
but another thing that happens is notice
that this shape is sort of getting
broader
uh
it's getting lower and fatter so that's
that's basically numerical diffusion
it's a it's a property of the algorithm
and as i mentioned before for the
algorithm to be
to
reproduce the exact solution
u must be
[Music]
uh
equal to the dx over dt ratio
okay now back to our
periodic boundary condition problem
basically what we need to do is
we need to assign it the value of a
gradient at the boundary
and that's basically going to be
this
except
now because i
so i is 1
i have 1 and this is i minus 1. so this
can't be zero
because our array is not
not allocated over index 0.
but this has to be now the end
the right side of the domain because we
want it to
we want the shape to propagate
through the right side and to come out
from the left so
this is just going to be grid size
okay
one aside here so i mentioned our array
is not defined over index 0.
so
by default
fortune array in this is start from 1.
so for example when you allocate or when
you declare
h to be of size grid size it's valid
indices are from 1 to grid size
0 is undefined
however you can also do
an arbitrary range so you could define
array to go from -20
to 50
and now this array will its first index
is going to be minus 20.
and
its elements are going to step forward
all the way to 50 and are also going to
include
index 0.
okay so we think we're good here
uh let's run
to see if our periodic boundary
conditions worked
oh hey andre i just see your message now
ah yes yes single precision
hello jason
okay
so we ran let's refresh
ah
not what i expected so let's see where i
messed up
hmm
so the gradient at the first point is
going to be that and then
okay i see what's happening
so
we assigned the value of the gradient at
index one but we still haven't
calculated
water elevation at x1 because we're
still looping it
from 2 to grid size so
i also need to do h of 1
equals
this
so we have a bit of a code repetition
here that's fine
so this is
still a work in progress um we'll have a
chance to clean it up and really nicely
refactor this at the end
okay let's make sure they save this
run it
so now i'm expecting to see
my water took
water to come up from the other side
okay great
so you see that now our
our wave is propping through the end of
the domain
and coming out from the other side
so it worked
very good
okay um
now notice this um
repetition in code that we have so we
need to we calculate gradient
explicitly using the same formula at
index one and then h
one i think this one so
that's basically um
needed just for the boundary conditions
and it just adds up
extra code unnecessarily so let's try to
refactor this a bit
and this is where i'll
introduce
whole array arithmetic
so basically
uh whole array arithmetic in fortune
allows you to perform
arithmetic over all elements of
of an array at once
by simply applying operations directly
to the array and not the individual
elements
so what it means is
that we can
we can actually use
index slicing here
to
to do away with the loop
so
let's see
dx
uh and we're gonna loop from two
to grid
size and it's going to be equal to
grid size minus
1 the grid size
and in fortune similar to
uh
to python if you're starting from
if you're slicing from the very
beginning of your array you can omit the
first index
so
one two grid size is equivalent to this
let's be explicit for now
and i should be able to
replace this loop
with this array form
and then
we can do the same for
the water height
do the grid size
great size
and you know what because
evaluating h at
index 1 actually has the same form
[Music]
as this it doesn't need to be outside of
the loop
so we could have placed as easily
yeah so this was actually just
this
and this is not possible because we're
evaluating dhdx
a priori
but that also means that now i can
write my whole array arithmetic much
simpler
for h so now because we're going from
one to grid size
which is the whole extent of my array
actually i don't need to slice the array
at all
so i can do away with these
okay
now this looks much better
much closer to our mathematical
formulation
and let's run it to make sure i didn't
mess anything up
of course i did wait let's see
fpn build
ah
see another useful error message from
the compiler
shapes of operands
are not conformable
so here i actually
meant to type
to grid size minus one so the two arrays
are staggered
and they must be the same shape
let's make sure it builds okay the
builds
let's run it and plot it to make sure
that we get exactly the same result as
before
okay
okay good
uh
exactly as before
so now i can
get rid of this
get rid of this
so now we have this
special boundary condition
and we have our
whole array evaluation or water height
so now our code is much
much simpler and shorter
but this this boundary condition
statement here is still
pretty verbose and kind of ugly
so i think now is a good time to
refactor this into a function
and
to do this i'll
basically make a module to contain the
function
now
fpm uh assumes modules to be
in
src
uh
and i'm gonna
call
my
source file mod def f90
so now we have
an empty
file mod diff
and another assumption that fpm requires
is
that your
module name
is named the same way as the source file
that it contains so i named my source
file mod div
and my
module is going to be mod this
and
this
okay so just like with program and
recall that i did
so i had program statement and here i
have end program statement
similar with
module
so module statement has a module name
and then we
finish it with end module
technically the language lets you just
say end
so you
you don't need any module it's perfectly
valid code but
it's actually more readable to say n
module you also don't have to say
the name of the module in the end module
statement
i like to do so i think it makes
the code more readable especially when
your module becomes a bit bigger it
spends
uh
more than the size of your screen so you
actually
you know sometimes you're not sure hey
uh which module does this and modules
didn't belong to so i'm just going to
use it
as a habit
like before we use implicit non
and so modules and fortune are basically
they're
it's a place where you can
declare
variables to be reused
uh you can define types in there
and you can define functions and
subroutines in it
and then from the program you can import
function subroutines variables
from the module
so
this module is going to
contain
my function this
so i'll call it diff
basically i'm implementing now finite
difference function
so i want to
i want to put this
inside the function and i also want to
bake the
boundary condition inside the function
as well so so that actually here
we can just do
diff
of x when our function is implemented
uh
we haven't implemented it yet so i'll
keep this commented away
for the time being and
this will take
x
which is real so now in
opening
defining the function statement again
like with programming module you just do
n function
this to close it
you don't need to separately
specify implicit none inside of function
if it is decide the defined in the
module and you have implicit none
at the top of your module
so as long as you always specify aimless
implicit not at the top of the module
you're all good with accuracy typing in
your function subroutines
okay function death
of x
fortune functions and subroutines uh
uh when you declare arguments you also
specify intent
so intent in means that x is an input
argument
it's not an output argument and
it can't be modified
inside this function
so we'll do x
and
we'll just put a column here uh so
basically
uh putting a column here for the array
for the argument inside the function
means that it will accept
any any size array so if you pass it an
array of 10 elements
it will work on that if you pass it an
array of thousand elements
same
so
right now our function doesn't do
anything yet
and let me just make sure that
our flow works with fbn so here i'm
gonna
do
actually before implicit none we have
the use statement use mod diff
only
diff
okay so i'm just going to import this
function i'm not going to do anything
with it yet the function doesn't do
anything yet
it's an empty function
and let's see if
if we can build it
and what that looks like
okay
so
we got a warning now we got an error
contain function div has no implicit
type
[Music]
aha
yes i exactly what the compiler is
telling me though but
i'm so used to kind of doing this on
autopilot that um
it didn't click immediately so because
of implicit none
diff needs to be typed
so
our input argument is real
and the result
is going to be real so we can specify
directly in
the function statement or you can
specify it
in the body of the function for example
it would be
real
real death and it would be size of x
but
actually you know what i do need to
specify it
in the body because it's an array the
result is an array so
i need to do
a real
death
and
basically the size of this server the
size of the result is going to be the
size of the input argument
so let's see if that fixes it
yes build
warning return value of this not set
okay we expected to see that that's fine
but see what happened now so i just put
a new module in src
and i put the use statement in my main
program
and fpm could on its own figure out that
how to build the module and the program
so that the program can use it
so now if we look at
my build directory
we have
aha so in the app it's still just the
object file and
and the executable and in tsunami
directory we have
the static library
which contains the
the module functions
we have the
the compiled uh
module file so this is something
specific to to fortran and
these module files uh vary between
compilers and compiler versions
but it's basically just um
an aid for the compiler uh in the
process and
something you don't necessarily have to
worry about it other than that they have
to be generated by the same compiler so
you can't reuse a mod file
from
a different compiler
and this is the compiled object file
okay so this is pretty great
i didn't need to specify anything in fpm
tunnel
for fpm to build this correctly
now
let's get back to our function
so i want to implement this
inside a function so i can just call it
as diff
okay let's just do
so
actually i just want the finite
difference here i don't want
uh to divide with dx yet so i want to do
that outside of the function
and
we need to declare
create size
and grid size
is going to be size of x
and then we're gonna do
this at one is
x
x
here i'm just renaming
the variable names so they're
inside a function they're more generic
we don't necessarily want to associate
them with any specific physical quantity
and now in my main program
i should be able to do
just this
and
if the output didn't change that's going
to be a good sign
but hold on now i have an error so in
that mean
f of x ah
yeah we want the depth of h
okay
okay so now we're not using d h over d d
h underscore dx anymore and the compiler
is correctly warning us about it
if the results are
correct we can clean it up
and it works great
okay so let's
let's enjoy the fruits of our labor by
removing all this junk and now we have
this very nice
single
one liner
don't need this anymore
and that's it
so our program is now much simpler
than when we were doing this in explicit
loops
and
if you if you follow the book or the
free ebook you'll see that they also
abstract this initialization away in a
in an external subroutine uh so we won't
do that
in this stream
in the interest of time
but i do want to
now that we have implemented this
correctly i want to go ahead and move
forward
to my step two uh where we'll solve
the
complete equations
uh there will be one important uh
difference
so we're adding these additional terms
but now that we have implemented
uh
the gradient operator del over del x
which is basically the diff function
now this is going to be much more
straightforward
to implement so we'll be solving for two
equations
i know it's getting late and
we're almost out of time
so
i'm gonna
run through this
fairly quickly
okay so
beside
beside h we'll also need u so let's
let's say this was our step one
and now for step two we'll have two
equations
so we'll have
dh over dt
you know what let me start with the
velocity
so the velocity equation is
u
times
d
dx plus g over
times d h over d x equals zero
which over d t
plus
d of
h times u
by d x equals zero
okay so this is basically the
the pseudocode
form of
these two equations and let me just i'm
just going to describe what each term
does
so
recall our one the equate one the
adduction equation which just moved uh
water in space without changing its
shape
uh
that term appears both in the velocity
or momentum equation
uh
here so this is the
this is the advection of velocity
but now because
the loss is advected by itself it
becomes a non-linear term and that's
going to introduce
sort of a chaotic behavior in the flow
chaotic just means that
small initial perturbations grow quickly
with time in non-linear systems so
that's
that's very common to
say weather and ocean flows
that are chaotic
and then this other term is
basically the pressure gradient or
uh
that's the work of gravitational
acceleration
on the water surface
so
this says that
velocity will increase
more if
the water surface is steeper
and this is this is pretty intuitive if
the water surface is pretty steep
uh
the water will want to run in that
direction very fast
if the slope is much gentler
the water will relax uh
with a lower velocity
and then the continuity our other
equation is basically just says that
volume of water has to be conserved
so when you have
a velocity pushing
into
into a focal area there will have to be
an a compensating increase in water
height
uh at that spot
similarly if you have
velocity pulling away there will be a
depression in the water
in the water height so together these
two equations uh make up
basically a simple 1d form of the
shallow water equations
and this is the smallest set of
equations that
is needed to reproduce somewhat
realistic
water waves
now
this doesn't include anything like
forcing by wind on the water surface or
uh internal dissipation nothing like
that so it will just be kind of
water sloshing around
okay so let's implement them real quick
now our
our u
uh won't be
a scalar parameter anymore it's gonna be
an array
and we'll solve for it
we'll have to edit the time step to
preserve stability
but let's uh we'll also need
gravitational acceleration
so that is going to be 9.8
we'll revisit the value of time step in
a bit
let's keep the same initialization of
our
water height to a bell shape and let's
initialize
u to zero
and now our
equation so i'm just gonna
sort of
copy this here for reference and then
i'm gonna implement it
underneath so
you will be updated as
minus
u times
f of u
divided by dx
plus gravitational acceleration g
times
okay
rotation acceleration
g times
d h d x so that's
the water surface slope and that's
basically just going to be def of h
divided by dx
good i think that's it for velocity
and now for h we're gonna have
minus so it's gonna be
you know what let me
save this for reference
the f of h times u
divided by dx
times dt aha we need
times dt here as well
now so far age has been
just a
sort of anomaly around zero
but we want to introduce some
[Music]
finite positive
mean water depth and that can be a
scalar
let's say
real parameter
let's call it
depth
i think in the book maybe i call this
h mean
i think that is maybe more appropriate
and let's set it to 10 meters
so now we're going to have
mean water depth of 10 meters
and any waves are going to be
perturbations on top
um
[Music]
and here we need to the depth plus h
but you know what now i realize that if
if depth is constant
then um
it doesn't matter inside the finite
difference so i don't think this will
affect our solution
okay
okay still 11 viewers good very good
i'm happy to keep going but we won't we
won't be too long we're almost done
okay
let's see if this
builds first
okay builds
over here
what does the output look like okay we
got a bunch a lot of numbers
and that means my
algorithm goes unstable
so
recall that earlier i
i still use the same
dx and dt so my time step is still one
second
but now i i added
all of these additional terms additional
physics
to the set
i actually need to greatly reduce my
time step to preserve stability
so
let's see if 0.1 is enough
okay still nada
let's try 0.01
yeah okay
so it runs true
um
without any nan so
nan is basically it stands for not a
number
and
a
variable gets a value of nan when
it its value goes out of frame so when
it's not any more representable by the
by the floating point
model
so
this can happen say if you divide
something uh by zero
or
if if you perform an illegal numerical
operation it goes on and nan is a very
common symptom of
numerical instability
in models
so now i believe in my book i had
0.2 seconds let's make sure that that
still works and now i'm going to run it
for
1000 time steps
so now 1000 time steps and 0.02
seconds time step that means that
my simulation is running for
20 seconds
yeah
okay
still getting nan
let's go back to 0.01
wait a second
so
let's see
did i mess anything up
this shouldn't be an issue but
also i don't think i need it so let's
remove that
okay let me see
um
u times
d view
d t
d x d t
looks good
okay the crash is off for a while
uh let's go a little bit lower with time
step
[Music]
really curious so let me try to
reproduce the solution from the books i
had
it's the same equations
u times the q over d x plus g d
over dx you know what we can refactor
this
let's get dx out of the parenthesis
did i initialize you you zero
aha you know what
i know what's the problem i also need to
update my algorithm i forgot about this
so
recall i mentioned earlier that i'm
using
an upwind
differencing so upwind differencing
worked well when we were moving
something in one direction from left to
right and we were differencing
then backward
from
from the current index to the back index
but now with these additional physics
terms we'll have water sloshing back and
forth
so we have velocities going
in both directions so this algorithm
actually becomes
unstable for that situation so i need
a centered
centered in space algorithm
and to do that let's just
real quick write another
another diff function and this one is
going to be
diff centered
okay it also takes x result is also
going to be
size of x
it suggests that
the differencing
will be now
across two grid grid points
and center in space
so i need to
go from two to grid size minus one
and that's going to be the difference
between
from three to grid size minus from one
to grid size minus two
okay now i also need to adjust my
boundary conditions
and now they need to be on both both
sides so i need
x
x 2 minus x at the end
divided by two
and diff at grid size
now because
the flow will be going both ways we need
specific boundary conditions on both end
so diff at the grid size is going to be
exit 1
minus x at grid size minus 1.
by 2
and i think this
so much for my
function
so while while we're at is actually
another useful thing to do in modules
when you have multiple
functions and when you have functions
that are meant to be
for internal use only
and functions are meant to be used by
the user
so it's a good practice to
declare everything is private private
means that it can't be imported from
outside the module
and then
explicitly declare what's public so
we're going to have diff upwind
and diff
centered
and then now in main
i actually want to use
diff
centered
now this
little trick here is
basically i'm renaming a function on
import so i'm saying i'm going to import
div centered
and i'm going to call it diff
so now i can
refer to this centered with just this
in my main code
and now let's try this
again
function
okay we get the error
function resultive upwind has no
implicit type aha okay
[Music]
okay
so
i declared it as as this
but now it's called default point
there's an easy solution here
and you can
add a result attribute to the function
statement
to just give it a short shortening
to the result so now i'm saying i'm
gonna refer to the result as this
so this becomes valid
and i'm gonna do the same here
okay
nothing to change in maine let's rebuild
and run
okay we work through all thousand time
steps
uh
without hitting an nan numerical
instability which is good news
uh notice that so
this actually ran pretty slow
uh
and that's because
first of all by default fpm builds
builds code in with all the bug flags
enabled
so no
no
compute optimizations of any kind
and another thing is that we're printing
the whole array to screen
in every time step so printing to screen
will also slow down
the execution
but with optimizations and without
printing to screen but perhaps
writing to file directly
actually this this runs blazing fast
so
now let's try to go back and fix our
time step can we run with
0.02
fpm run
no
i hit an end so let's try to go lower
0.01
it's quite possible i still have a
glitch somewhere
perhaps it may find a differencing
okay
this all looks good to me
okay let's see what uh what the output
looks like
sometimes that's just more informative
than looking at numbers
so half thousand time steps i don't want
to plot
every time step actually i'm gonna you
know what i had it open here
so let's plot every
every fifth
and then
run
we're plotting and making a new movie
now
and let's see
what the output looks like
okay so
so what happens is that we have our
initial bulge
it begins to depress
as we go in time so that's that's what
we expect
the gravity to act to
pull
basically pull water down
and
to accelerate on either side
but as we accelerate we develop these
spurious
uh
spurious oscillations
now let's see if i can
reproduce the parameters from
from the book exactly because i know
that one was
was stable
so that one used
dk of 0.02 it was a bit sharp
let's see if that will help
but otherwise if not i won't
dwell too long on this
often these kind of
numerical issues are pretty difficult to
diagnose
but the key point for this stream was
really the fortune implementation of the
code
um
still
so let's see what's different
you know what you know from the top of
my head actually so i don't think that
it would matter but
maybe
the depth parameter mattered here
and let's
let's add depth
and set it to 10 meters
and run this again
i have the i have the implementation
from the book here on my other screen
you can see it
so i'm using it now now because i'm
running into issues i'm using it for
reference
because i know that one runs correctly
let's see if we can
okay a little bit better
so
i still get these spurious oscillations
but
at least i'm able to
preserve
roughly the shape of the wave
what happens with
a longer time step
should only make it worse i think
but
it doesn't hurt to try
okay i expected to see
expect to hit some nans there but
didn't get him yet
okay
[Music]
okay i don't know
what else to try here
[Music]
so let me just double check this
equation again
that looks good
yeah u times h
okay
uh
let's make it a wrap here um
the so basically the end result is our
wave i still have some numerical issues
here
but that's fine for
for one evening
i think pretty good
and
i hope this gave you a good
a nice flavor or
a good taste of fortran
and how it can be used for
numerical stuff
and i want to do one more thing which is
to show you a really cool feature of fpm
before we wrap up
and that is um
basically
how you can very easily include an
external dependency in your fortran
project
and let me go back here to
to packaging
so
brad richardson
the lead developer of the haskell client
he recently added this capability
which allows you to pull remote
dependencies from github automatically
or really any other
publicly available git repository
so let's see where is that
adding the panel says okay
so i'm going to show you how you can
add a simple dependency
in
your fortune project so
you'll have this block
dependencies
and then you're going to specify
git equals
was it git yeah oh no
it's the name of the project name of the
package and then
equals curly braces and then git url
so i'm going to pull my own
daytime library
basically it's going to be daytime
equals
get equals
and then we're going to do https
github.com
wave scientific
daytime fortran
so here you can also
optionally specify tag i believe and if
you don't by default it will pull
the code from master
branch
and just for a demo
here i'm going to say
use
datetime
i believe it's daytime module
only
datetime
uh so datum is basically a fortune
library that allows you to work with
dates and times here i'm just going to
use it for a demo to demonstrate
type datetime is
now
i'm going to use it to print
the current time to screen
print star
now
time
and then you can
use uh
the sdrf time
format string to to format your
you want your time to be output
this is somewhat similar to the
iso date format
and here i'm just gonna because i'm
doing this time demo i'm just gonna stop
here
so the stop statement will end the
program right there
uh now notice that
i didn't put this module file
anywhere in my project
uh
i i'm only including it here in the main
program
and
i only specified two fpm in its tomo
file where to find date time
and that should be good enough
so let's do fpm
run
and
now you see that
fbm went
and
saw that i asked for daytime from this
url
it cloned the repository
it compiled for me
and it made it available to my main
program completely automatically
which is uh pretty amazing
and i'm personally really excited about
this capability for fortune development
we did get a kind of an ugly output
uh let's fix that let's see why that is
so
okay
so
i didn't initialize
my daytime instance now
and that's why i'm getting this
sort of
default value
of time
so now equals daytime
oh no now equals now now
so maybe actually now wasn't
it wasn't the best name for this let's
call it current time
because now
is the name of the method it wouldn't be
an issue so fortune would still let you
do it
but
it's just ugly to call something
uh now
now percentage now
okay
let's rename this current time
fpm run all right
so i got my current uh
local machine time
[Music]
in the terminal
i didn't have to
get the library myself
from github fbm did all that
for me it built it for me
and it took care of all the
dependency
handling
for me so this was very easy to is it's
an easy way to incorporate the
dependency into your project
now of course
it does require that the dependency
itself is fpm enabled that it has an fpm
uh donald package
uh
i'm sorry it has an fpm tunnel file
so let me just show you what it looks
like
in daytime
scientific
daytime fortran
so this is a recent addition so you see
fpm tunnel is specified
in the top level directory
and let's see what it looks like so it
has these
this metadata stuff name version license
blah blah blah
and it
it specifies how to build um
here and and basically the only thing
here that needs to be explicitly
specified is how to run tests
for it so that you can also
when you work with daytime directly you
can just do fpm test and it will run the
test for you
but otherwise this is it just this
simple file allowed
uh daytime to be included as an fbm
dependency here
and okay that being said uh that's all
folks for tonight
i'm looking forward to actually doing
more streams i'll probably start my own
[Music]
twitch channel
so i'll keep you posted on it
if you don't know um how to follow me
basically you can
let's see uh probably my
personal website
yeah on my personal website my
firstnamelastname.com you can find my
email at the end
feel free to write ask me any questions
about the book fortran or whatever
definitely check out the fortunalang
website
and also i forgot to mention earlier
the learn page will be home to
various specific tutorials which will be
great for learning various aspects
for fortn right now we have this quick
start fortune tutorial where you can
learn these
uh basic features of the language
there's also the compilers page with all
the fortran compilers both open source
and commercial
we looked at community
and there's also
an index of packages
on this page so this is basically a
registry of
various fortune libraries and tools
that you can use for your work
okay uh
last but not least definitely if if
you're curious to learn more take a look
at this um free ebook
it's a great way to get a taste about
the full book
so you can
see if you like the book before
committing your money
to to buy the full copy
and of course the full copy you can find
at
manning.com
book slash modern fortran